we take these away quick
[Music]
hi I'm Pete crouch I'm Tom for ice I'm
Chris stark and this is snack wars for
sport by one yeah the food between it
was very nice actually
loved it they're distinct like a meat
thing on a meatballs no well yeah
there's that as well but there's Whedon
or I can definitely Sweden Gong crashing
yeah fish bula what is that fish oh yeah
crank it open it we've got pork pies as
well no it's the game I though oh oh
jelly oh my god oh my god that's like
scallops and Bob it is listen I'm not
looking forward to this you turn it
upside down that's the
well I reckon I've been sick while I
like that we take these away quick I
can't get I can't get it down oh yeah
that was I was genuinely that was
horrific
I obviously I've tried to get that down
shall we so we've got your classic
liquorice allsorts yeah I found a Bertie
Bassett I'm not human
do I fear these are right that's a
little bit of licorice this could be
pure unadulterated oh that's disgusting
what would this or a monkey I'd give it
to him it's nice and Swedish one facets
liquorice allsorts are better than the
jungle wah ah okay so from England I'm
guessing we've got the mint humbug yeah
the classic mint humbug Asura and salty
kryptonite are they are disgusting have
you had these before no I have a
specific brand but I'm familiar with a
salty Scandinavian sweet really it's not
a sweets it's salty it's disgusting
that's you one from Troy oh great wait
doesn't even feel meaning to it just
hits you straight
that's nothing to enjoy that you like
I'm gonna crack on with the the humbug
there it says in the back hora de wash
our hands Chris I'm going humbug mmm
yeah I know what humbug tastes like
surfer yeah
got three two one hello Sweden okay that
looks like Marmite either what is this
caviar caviar now you might like a bit
of fat before dice for this is right as
we all know you like the finest most
caviar what this it is pitch oh the fish
roe is fishing is it the penthouse
really not then it puzzles me why she's
I don't I don't know I really need to
taste this I get this morning why don't
we mix it up why don't we go surf and
turf what the caviar on the Marmite
I don't know well both have a little
breakfast I don't need textures are
quite good could you get the crispy
cracker the sticky Marmite and then the
before what's it like I can't be good
if Marmite obviously only shines on mama
mama mama will you come here I'll just
do that Carl's really nice but they
don't we've seen the best of Swedish
cuisine here
[Laughter]